[Music]
twin siblings twin peaks' twin citys
twin planets two earths one solar system
how would that work where would a second
earth be located is it possible for two
planets to share one orbit with the
people on another earth be the same as
us would we be in touch this is what if
and here's what would happen if there
was another earth in our solar system in
2015
NASA's super-powerful Kepler space
telescope discovered the closest copy of
Earth to date
it's called kepler 452b nicknamed earth
2.0 kepler 452b it's a star about the
same size as our Sun every 385 days
earth 2.0 is positioned within a
habitable zone relative to its star
meaning that it's not too hot and not
too cold and it's likely to have a rocky
surface too while this planet could
plausibly be a cousin to earth it's
about 1,400 light-years away from our
solar system but suppose we had a second
earth in our solar system
two identical earths with perhaps the
only difference existing between their
respective inhabitants how long would
this scenario last is it gravity or a
rival species that we need to fear most
if we're gonna fit another earth
anywhere in our solar system our best
bet is somewhere between our planet and
Mars our earth is on the inner edge of
the solar system's habitable zone and
with Mars closer to the outer edge
anything past it might be a little too
cold for a species like ours let's
imagine another earth that's close
enough to our own so that its
inhabitants are comfortable is this a
stable situation that would depend on
your definition of stable the prospect
of two planets sharing the same orbit is
possible but it wouldn't last forever
eventually the gravitational interaction
between both planets would either cause
the two of them to collide or one would
end up pushing the other one towards the
Sun and we'd be back to just
on earth I hope it's ours but don't let
that scare you it's possible that two
planets could Co orbit in harmony for
billions of years before anything bad
happened
another possibility is a binary planet
system in which two earths of comparable
size could have separate orbits with one
orbiting the other think of the moon the
earth and the Sun see how the moon
orbits the earth but how they both end
up going around the Sun but since we're
talking about two planets of similar
size and gravitational attraction it's
more likely that these two earths would
swap positions we've already got a
real-life example of this with two of
Saturn's moons Epimetheus and Janus
about every four years whichever moon is
closer to saturn has a shorter orbital
period and catches up to its cousin as
they get closer the two moons pull on
each other causing one to slow down and
the other to speed up the one on the
inside gain speed and moves out the one
on the outside loses speed and falls
closer to Saturn but then of course the
closer moon to Saturn adopts a shorter
orbital period speeds up and overtakes
its cousin in about another four years
but what we've seen moons do this we've
yet to discover a binary planet system
let's just suppose that's how it works
two earths either sharing an orbit or
swapping between two now assuming that
the second earth is inhabited by
intelligent life forms and that they've
evolved at relatively the same speed as
our own human species how would we
interact with one another it's
impossible to say whether we'd look the
same or act the same much less speak the
same language twin planets don't
necessarily mean twin species but before
we start dreaming up intergalactic trade
or warfare maybe we could start with
something a little simpler maybe we
start trying to learn from each other
establishing communication through radio
waves or satellites if they speak the
same language
perhaps a friendly visit wouldn't be too
far off and if they don't it'll be quite
the learning curve but we'll get there
think about it
we put a man on the moon in the 1960s
and we've accomplished a lot more since
will you visit another earth in your
lifetime nope but if you're wondering
what else could be out there keep
watching what if